hello I'm Jeffrey thank you everyone of
for coming you're all fantastic Benedict
with respect to the cast members it was
worth it for them not coming because
your hair is magnificent Sweden and sooo
since this is Comic Con in the place for
big announcement let's get it on the
table seasons
a five six theatrical movie and Benedict
since Steven says you have the power of
the greenlight feel free to do that as
well I see so the compliment was was
loaded well everyone else can suck it
anyway for more parts oh god I can
explicitly reveal that there won't be a
fifth season but there will be a sixth
in 2020 yes but I'm 15 chew on that
why is everybody assuming they survive
series four oh yeah I told you it was
dark it's just like Star Trek if you
like stories no electricity in it one of
them it's spider-man ID yeah spider-man
what's your name my name is Josh Garcia
said it you see him I'm sure about your
name I know I said it that exact same
way when I met Morgan Freeman and I made
him laugh Oh Morgan Freeman everyone is
since our stars and our producers have
relatives on the set how does that help
you during the production process
relatives on the set you mean like
having your family clothes while they're
working such intense I mean me why can
my mom and dad's very softly yes I do
that's wonderful thing yeah it's
wonderful yeah it's really great I mean
you know it's you'd think it would be an
easy thing for that to happen and it is
for parents to play your parents and you
know I love you so much I've got so much
respect for them as does the industry at
large and I think people who've seen
their work as well you know they I'm a
dad so I love them to bits but they've
really really good at their job so it's
it's a thrill for me it's a thrill for
me and it's just slightly hard for mum
sometimes when she turns around says
Sherlock and she just I could see her
brain going Joe
rather than Ben or Tim or Sofia one of
the other names I get before I get my
benefit
I happens I'm that no god bless them
it's it's it's a joy what's not love
it's really great Thank You mr.
spider-man uh what is your name hi my
name is Maureen thank you guys for all
coming um I know we touched on this a
little bit earlier but I want to know
how was filming writing and producing
the Victorian special different from
modern day it was much more expensive it
was um also it's the first one that you
to have actually written together
yeah you've done again on this sue as
well it was a great was a joy it was it
was it was longer it was it was
obviously more expensive but you know
just getting all the frocks out as it
had the Fox and the whole that lovely
lovely feel that you know we said from
the beginning wanted it to be a big
Christmas treat I said it's like when
you get into a Christmas pudding and you
find the silver sixpence inside and then
you break up for six months and there
are four more pudding that's what I mean
and it was just we just kind of put it
with every sort of treat we shall our
cover sheet we could imagine say it was
it was real joy I've never seen you two
look happier and on the right and back
full day that was fun yeah
Laurie I see a Sherlock on top of the
fall you must go exactly yeah what is
that strange thing you know because
obviously having done our version on the
roof of bars like that it's obviously
makes sense for a 21st century program
but then to actually give yourself the
chest do it and to build really because
the real Reichenbach Fall forgive me God
is a little disappointing and to build
the one from your imagination which does
everything you wanted to do Danny
Hargreaves amazing work on that effect
it was just it was great and the
post-production of it is Emmy nominated
I believe I think it was thank you
so you brought so just bring up Moriarty
because there's a really sort of it's
very quick but you utter something I
think maybe in last foul I think but
it's about addiction and how you're you
know you do you solve crimes essentially
to sort of to deal with your addiction
do you think Moriarty is a part of that
addiction do you think he's necessary
for you
we had the work addiction yeah
absolutely um you know the thing he's
addicted to to things that destroy him
and in a way or will have the potential
to destroy him and one is his archenemy
and what he's up to and the other is is
drugs only what he's not working that
that slips back in again um and you'll
just have to wait see how that all plays
in a bit sorry what is your name
uh my name is Joe I'm from Solvang
California hey guys come on up wine
tasty you can stay at my place oh [ __ ]
thank you we put on a Tuesday Oh Timmy
okay sorry Joe
it's all bangs a little Dutch town in
the middle of California it's really
glad you could go stay with Joe yeah but
will Connor next time okay um Artie I
was reading an IGN that a four seasons
going to be the last season uh why is
that and do you think you might be
willing to come back later when you're
older for you know older Sherlock
because Sherlock's awesome okay all
right let's navigate that one um so you
said the foot did you say the four
seasons nah I never said that we have no
idea whether it will be the last one or
not ah we just haven't said that just
hit one of the one feature you have to
understand about being interviewed is
it's almost pointless turning up to an
interview these days they make it up I
think I should just phone up and say do
what the hell you like I never said it
was the gonna be like she's explicitly
said I'd be very surprised if this
season is the last one and the headline
said
Moffat says the season is the last
yeah what can you do I think media
coverage now and I think there's just
they don't care they don't give a [ __ ]
they're just like well some of those
words were in that just put it up there
we're in the ocean truth we'll come on
out here that's true so we don't know we
always talk about to carry on and then
everyone loves the show and we'd love to
carry on
hello what is your name oh he's got a
coat get it off him
we need the coat I like your coat thank
you it's always wear that coat yeah I'll
probably die ahead it's awesome yeah
well there's my world Brad Elkins might
well feel the opening that's fine
good good my name is Chris and my
question is for mr. Cumberbatch um
you've played a cerebral character here
in Sherlock and are going to be again in
Doctor Strange so how do you approach
these cerebral characters and did
anything from playing Sherlock help you
prepare for Doctor Strange um
no to the latter question no not really
um dr. Strange's right he has no no no
sure looks a lot more I think strange
and strangers Tregenna um I think that's
the difference you know strange is fully
humanized I mean he does seek control
through he seeks control through the
perfection of his work he's a workaholic
there are some crossovers and like you
said that he's smart but he doesn't cut
off emotional ties he does have physical
relationships he is very much a man of
of a sensory world and shark isn't
search Sherlock's certainly tries to
tail those appetites to concentrate on
being the best
consulting detective another one softly
detective in the world so now the
crossovers a very slight and also
culturally utterly different one's very
English one's very American
what's the first part the question can't
remember what what about the question
was will you go stay with Joe and so on
yeah the first by the question what was
it I promise I'm old bird iya - but can
you can you go back and say just
generally how's your approach when you
when you're acting a sort of cerebral
character oh you just you make sure you
get really smart writers to give you
what gracious battery but the monologues
the monologues the kid that's how that's
how I feel and I read when I found a
beautiful but that's a lot of work it
just takes a lot of time a lot of the
longest monologue you've seen how many
pages Tuesday morning um didn't wanna in
no way I think I know yeah the best
man's speech where he goes that was
about was a good good four pages if not
five I think I don't you know because it
comes off the end of the speech and he
bolts over the table and that was I
think about a five days shooting it was
like doing it was like doing a sort of a
weird one-man play with the most amazing
group of actors kind of going to be
there having a lot of fun though I have
to say as well as being supported they
were they were enjoying bright lights to
Bristol I was tucked up and this
marathon would be going off yeah rotten
rotting we went out on the last night
they remember we did I've never had a
better release it was gonna show that
going out them to the point that I
remember there was one paparazzi their
fathers and he was in a car taking
photographs out this little silver micro
business on mica and I lost him this
time Mike respond I'm they're fine but
got the rat back and this one was a pain
in the ass and say he was taking
photographs but we this is the wrong way
around me we just we went around him and
started taking which is good in him and
his car he's try to hide it looks easy
but anyway that was that was that was
that was the hardest one definitely the
best man speech I thought what kind of a
weird question which is do you think
Sherlock really wants to connect with
another person on a normal level do you
think he would trade some of the
high-functioning sociopath II the
world's greatest detective if he could
connect with another person I think what
if RC lens is in order to be the best
consulting detective he has to do that
it's part of his ask it to understand
people better he has to become more of a
person and it's it's not just sentiment
that brings him to it's not whimsy its
its effectiveness as much as anything
else there is a practical element to
being part of the world that you're
trying to understand that makes him a
better detective and you know this
friendship is utterly reliant on that
and he's he's loyal to watching the way
loyal what's in his loyal team because
that symbiosis because he takes him into
the world in a way that makes it
possible for him to function better as a
detective and that's that's primarily
where the where the friendship you know
is is formed is it's founded and it is a
real friendship you don't think yes it
seems like ever like everyone in his
life it has some sort of a function that
is yes yes that is coldly true but I
think through that you know as it's the
case you you form an affection and while
that may be a weakness to a degree for
other people that try to attack him and
and and use those soft points those
targets it in the end it makes him a
greater person and it sounds a bit soapy
this love conquers all
it does and tumblr just got pregnant
again again I think we have time for one
more question what is your David what is
your question hi my name is Amanda and
my question is for Benedict Marc and
Amanda my question is what was your
first line from Caesar II series for Oh
Oh Amanda that was the life really good
now the producers are furiously working
out if that gives anything away or got
it oh my I know mine but I don't have to
say see where they louder Darla you mean
you mean things we shot first or
actually for the thing I the actual line
in the script the first line in the
story that oh sure I know fine but that
was of course I was yes shapes
oh yeah that's racist I do that
I don't know 90 more because also
because we think we change that um
summit take potatoes I do this very
revealing it's a really good question
without sorry well thank you for trying
thank you for the brilliant question
about good question we let go sorry
surely mr. boffin wouldn't disappoint oh
how could he look at these gorgeous
faces and break their hearts no but you
can't you know that's why it's important
you know that we I think you think you
want to know but you don't want to know
and that's what's great about waiting I
feel like we get so spoiled in our
culture with binge watching
oh you Joe you'll find out you'll find
out that much more worth it
did we that much more worth it but this
I mean Asia compose exercise this
because we're trying to make you know
manage expectations at the same time not
give us a anyway yeah in that case we
just couldn't remember what no that's
fine I'll tell you what right maybe this
will be a substitute you guys
occasionally will do keep three word
keywords yes
so Stephen and Marc just three three
keywords for oh we've got one each me
and Sue and the last one is incendiary
but not the word incendiary I can't say
wait we're not we're not doing words
this time we're doing name names okay I
thought you got to do noises for a
minute that yeah that's dangle oh yeah
okay the first word first what is I'm
enjoying this 30 forgotten first word is
Thatcher Oh Smith Oh
sharing food no gee I didn't hear I
didn't put a genius batcher Smith Sharon
Sharon for sure I know there's an answer
but suit you not you what is the title
of the Christmas special reasons gonna
tell you because I can't
oh just watch the the abun I can't do ha
ha
how do you ever proud of the my chronic
obesity saying they've on the tongue
come down stick this is special it's
fine we got past the crab right right
yeah well add bright I want to that
that's the we're almost done with the
panel but I did want to point out not
only was this Amanda's first time at
comic-con this was Benedict's first time
as Sherlock
they legitimately came out just for a
couple of days just to be here just for
you because this is the this is the
place to come
really really a song measure and a joy
and life is a no no no you know please
didn't granny will say thank you I want
to say thank you you know it's nice to
go to sign off and say thank you thank
because you're curing your cosplay the
hours you spend you know making this
event what it is well thank you but I'm
trying to say that we love you don't
take that the wrong way I'm not giving
it back as you can have your love I'm
saying then it works both ways because
it is it's extraordinary and it's
inspiring and it's completely
overwhelming and utterly humbling it
really is it really is so thank you we
were gonna Mandarin I just say hello to
our clay eyeball sky and angel we met
that I know hello we met the muscle is a
little thing for you ro nice we met them
outside the lift last night yeah they
were lovely hello hello but I think but
I think it's evident I mean we did the
we did the marble rehearsal panel Friday
night Benedicta been up since like 6
o'clock in the morning and rehearsal was
almost went to midnight and still he
went out and hung out with fans all
along the way in line for haulage so I
know what he says is sincere and I know
they appreciate it you're all the reason
that it happens
you